a massive response in support of a
president's troubled agenda
tens of thousands of Colombians hitting
the call of Gustavo Petro the country's
first leftists have a state in defense
of his ambitious social and economic
reforms
among them workers labor unions students
and 18 000 indigenous Colombians from
across the country
the reforms are very necessary for the
Colombian people like land reform in the
hands of the few and all the other
reforms that would benefit the people
we are here to sub change a change
towards reforms that previous
governments owed us so much in terms of
Labor and we seek to vindicate ourselves
by doing so
change has been hard to come Health
labor Agriculture and education bills
presented by the government and aimed at
changing the face of one of the most
unequal countries in the world have all
been lagging in Congress a year after
taking office Petro's initially wide
Coalition with traditional parties has
fallen apart and Petrus plunged in the
polls
at the end of the rally the president
himself calling for a national agreement
with the country's establishment
I propose to former president to the
richest to the parties to the business
associations to all of you to talk about
these great issues truth education and
land reform as the basis for peace in
Colombia
but this rally comes just a month before
Regional elections that are seen as a
referendum on Petra's Administration
polls suggests a majority of Voters
could turn their backs and governments
candidates
I think that this demonstration while
undoubtedly the most important so far is
more than anything a preventative
measure against what will probably be an
electoral defeat in October so when
traditional parties will further lose
incentive to be part of a government
Coalition Petra will have this card to
play popular support in the streets in
the end the president got the turnout he
had hoped for to reinvigorate this
message but most here believe that
without a strong showing of its
candidates in the upcoming Regional
elections moving forward as many reforms
will remain very difficult Alessandra Al
Jazeera Bogota
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera